hey what's up guys so the highlight of
the sunken crown DLC was the level
design and in my opinion the highlight
of this second piece of DLC the iron
crown is the difficulty so what's the
trend here with these two things well
both of these things make it feel more
like Dark Souls 1 and that's a good
thing most of this video is going to be
me talking about the difficulty and
whether I think it's done well or
whether I think it's done poorly I think
it's done well but before we get into
that I want to talk about your first
impressions of the DLC I personally love
it when games have a powerful beginning
because you're setting the tone for
what's to come
and you need to intrigue the player so
that they're motivated to continue and
arguably souls games need to do this
even more than other games because
they're actually difficult you know they
have to make you want to play for
example sunken crown did this when it
had sin fly overhead you saw him and you
thought damn I'm gonna have to fight
that huge ass dragon aren't I the core
game also does that with the King
vendrick it hypes up the fact that you
are eventually going to find this King
so at the start of this DLC you see a
bunch of for the Knights of drangleic
covered in ash and surrounding a
national creature
they clearly died assaulting it it
inspires your imagination you then
access the main area via this chain
which is a really cinematic experience
and as you arrive in this second tower
you notice a few more things firstly the
whispering it feels haunted you know
that first abandoned how you just
explored that one felt dead but this one
this one feels alive the source of the
whispering is found quickly and it's a
very similar being to the one you just
saw before you even take it out using
your logic you remember the first
smelter wedges that were found on the
first ashen maiden so clearly those
smelter wedges are the things that you
need to shove into this woman's chest
and when you do so you realize huh I got
a boss soul from that and you're not
expecting to get a boss soul so early so
it inspires you to read the item
descriptions and figure out the story
behind this tower turns out you're going
to be finding these vessels housing the
Queen throughout the entire
our for the Queen has arrived this land
after the king has passed away and when
she got here she decided to infuse her
souls into multiple vessels and haunt
the tower through them you explore more
and it becomes clear that this place has
been long abandoned the empty throne the
unmoving gears the ash coating
everything it does a good job of
conveying history the only way forward
is down again as you go down you're
assaulted by the feeling that these
gears should be moving I talked to that
information away for later I knew that
if I could get the gears moving I'd be
able to access ledges that I couldn't
quite get to now and in fact when you
get them moving it's actually one of the
most satisfying things because you can
just dash all the way through the level
and witness everything you've gotten
past
so the first enemies you encounter
they're quite easy you learn their
moveset okay you've mastered fighting
them great because now you're ready to
be ambushed by six of them enchanted
with ashen protection of the maiden
while you're trapped in this room with
no easy way out thus begins a trend in
this DLC you are going to be dropped
into a lot of situations where the only
way forward is to fight when you look
back on this ambush you think it's
really well thought out it's tough but
fair because you've already been given a
chance to become familiar with the
enemies first off you've seen the ashen
maiden you know that she's influencing
the environment around her and if you
were inquisitive with the first one then
you should know how to destroy it the
only new element introduced here is the
ashen protection on the soldiers telling
you that these maidens don't just spout
pillars of fire like the first one they
actually affect their environment so the
game is introducing you to one new
concept at a time and since you you
intelligent gamer you know everything
already you run straight to the maid and
you take her out and then when the
soldiers are unprotected you can take
them out as well so sure it's an ambush
sure it's really punishing but the game
gave the inquisitive player a chance to
learn about everything that's done to
assault him so I think this is
difficulty executed well and hopefully
you didn't get executed a lot of people
might think this is too difficult and
I'm willing to hear your thoughts on it
I've actually got a straw
poll down below where you can actually
tell me what you thought about this DLC
just so you know speaking of something
that breaks the mold soon you'll come
across these Archer guys and in the DLC
notes that I have from design statement
is that they wanted an enemy that would
move in unnatural ways different than
all the other enemies that clearly
telegraph their moves and I think they
pulled it off the way this enemy flails
around awkwardly forces you to treat it
with caution and a little bit more
curiosity than you usually would most
players in this DLC will be fairly
experienced in anticipating attacks so
that they can roll through them and
messing up an enemy's way of attacking
is a neat trick by from to make that
experience less useful just after you
deal with this weird enemy you get to
one of the cruelest sections of the DLC
with a long difficult stretch before the
next bonfire hopefully you've got your
life gems ready because this bit is
brutal the game throws three different
combinations of difficult encounter at
you testing if you can conquer different
types of difficult scenarios before you
earn your bonfire so first is the
ability to cope with tons of enemies
with no escape the first encounter is
also testing your ability to survive
using your environment and the most
observant players will succeed here the
most observant players will chase a
bunch of these goofy barrel holding guys
down this hole dousing themselves in
water to reduce fire damage and then try
to blow up the entire room that's what I
think you meant to do anyway the second
gauntlet is this stretch that couples
ranged attack with melee enemies in a
narrow area it's enjoyable but the
biggest gripe I start to have with this
and with the entire DLC is that the game
is really starting to favor players who
have a ranged method of attack that said
it is immensely satisfying to hole
enemies off a cliff if you're a strength
build with a massive weapon so maybe
they had strength builds in mind here
too
the problem with that train of thought
is that the cliff doesn't actually have
a big enough drop to kill enemies so
you're going to encounter these enemies
that you throw off a cliff a little bit
later the third and final section is
filled with ambushes nothing new here
they taunt you with a bunch of items
lying on
ground and if you've pin playing Souls
games for this long you should probably
know what's coming your way if you
decide to get greedy and pick up those
items now these three things are fairly
standard examples of difficulty in a
Souls game you know they're testing your
combat ability and you've seen all this
before but there are a couple more
examples of difficulty in the DLC that
haven't really been done before in a
Souls game for example there's this one
part where you get to the end of a
corridor filled with traps and you
encounter this huge towering enemy who's
destined to chase you back along that
corridor you can use those traps to help
take him out and running from him while
trying to figure out how to take him out
is a really cinematic experience or at
least it was for me and next do you
remember that tower I mentioned before
without spoiling too much it has a red
phantom enemy within it
now usually red phantom enemies are the
worst enemy you can fight they move
cancel they have seemingly infinite
stamina but in the DLC they did a really
good job with them the red phantom
fights are actually a highlight because
of their AI and the best example of this
is mal drawn the assassin who I'm sure
you will become fairly familiar with if
you've played the game I'm not going to
spoil this one for people so let's just
say that he fights like a regular player
would and regular players usually fight
like scumbags at the bottom of this
tower is an item with significant
throwbacks to Dark Souls 1 and speaking
of the law one thing I can say is that
while the sunken crown story was fairly
self-contained and separate from the
main story of Dark Souls 2 the iron
crown DLC includes a ton of links to the
rest of the game in particular the story
of the old iron king so I'm looking
forward to covering that in the next few
days we'll conclude on the bosses there
is one optional boss that's a reskin
above previous boss one optional great
boss that has one of the coolest
environments to fight in and I'm
convinced that the mandatory boss fight
is the hardest fight in Dark Souls 2 to
date so this a few times now but if
you're looking for a challenge this DLC
has it I mean I spent about an hour or
two on this boss and that's
significantly more time
I spent than on any other boss my major
criticism of this DLC and the previous
DLC is the so-called coop areas that are
supposedly more difficult because
they're intended to be fought in coop
with other players now I like this
concept but I think they're being really
lazy in their execution of this concept
so far in these coop areas we've only
seen long stretches crammed with twice
the amount of enemies with no real
thought as to their placement or the way
a small group of players will interact
with them from school with these areas
is to counter how easy summoning makes
the game I get that I hate how easy
summoning makes the game and adding more
enemies achieves that goal yeah it does
but it sure as hell doesn't make it fun
design which leaves me wondering why did
they even bother instead of adding a
bunch of enemies from should create ways
for multiple phantoms to feel like
they're contributing or create ways for
different phantoms to fulfill different
roles for example what if one member of
your party needed to carry an item
through the level that attracted enemies
to him and stopped him from being able
to attacked and everyone else in your
party had to protect him what if every
member of your party needed to prove
themselves worthy of co-op by taking out
a mini-boss one-on-one what if there was
some sort of reward for killing the most
enemies in your group these ideas took
me the best part of five minutes to
think up and I'm really disappointed
that Fromm didn't have the time or the
motivation to put some thought into
enhancing these co-op sections because
like I said the idea is really good but
the execution has been terrible in the
last two DLCs and that is something I
really hope changes so to sum up these
co-op areas if you're going to create
co-op areas then you need to introduce
new mechanics that make use of having
multiple players not just a bunch more
enemies for me and my friends to beat on
but that is my only gripe really with
the DLC so far I honestly think that
from software has taken a lot of
criticisms for Dark Souls 2 on board and
I think they've shown they still have
the capacity to craft experiences that
rank alongside the best that the series
has to offer but what did you think of
the DLC like I mentioned before I've got
a
dropo below that you can vote in so just
like all the review sites out there you
can attribute an arbitrary score of how
good you thought the DLC was and I did
this because you know my opinion isn't
the only one that's important I really
want to see what you guys think and I
know that people value the opinions of
the masses as well so check out that
straw poll and that's it feel free to
rate the video and I'll catch you guys
in the next one which is